dans quelques minutes un couple de
jeunes mariés va prendre son envol
baptêmes d'hélico way un bon endroit
pour embêter main aux commandes captain
john 33 années de vol au compteur on va
décoller évoluer vers les chutes d'eau
regardez vos ceintures bien attaché vous
pouvez parler mais attention j'entends
tout ce que vous dites vous ai compris
attention j'ai entendu
[Musique]
c'est le coup d'envoi d'un séjour dont
il rêvait deux semaines de lune de miel
en jamaïque
un voyage romantique au pays du reggae
[Musique]
un périple à travers l'île découverte
par christophe colomb fut conquise par
les britanniques
rendu célèbre par ses pirate légendaire
[Musique]
à l'époque le pirate reynerie morgan
empressé bateaux ici et attendaient les
navires espagnols
depuis l'indépendance en 1965 les
touristes débarquent en masse en
jamaïque
trois millions de visiteurs chaque année
ce sont surtout des américains et des
canadiens à 80% ils séjournent dans des
hôtels gigantesque les enclaves d'où ils
le sortiront guerre
les français sont encore peu nombreux
trois mille cinq cents l'an dernier
des touristes à l'esprit pionnier qui
viennent découvrir une jamaïque plus
authentiques ou rendre hommage à une
légende bob marley la star du reggae
trente ans après sa mort il fait l'objet
d'un culte la jamaïque peut-être devenir
un nouveau paradis pour les français
pour bob marley pour la musique genre
convaincu sa femme de faire le voyage
anthony sera leur chauffeur ils ont 25
ans oriane est infirmière jean a monté
une petite entreprise d'électricité
une voiture avec chauffeur un programme
sur mesure et de beaux hôtels
le voyage va leur coûter très cher c'est
leur cadeau de mariage
ouais c'est parti pour la petite journée
un v6 alto et les drivers ici à la dont
je ne veux pas pleurer
la visite de la capitale commence par un
passage obligé au stade de kingston bob
marley ya donnèrent de ses concerts
mythiques en 1978 devant quarante mille
personnes
ça me procure des sensations que que je
pensais pour obtenir ce statut à tout ça
je l'avais eue dont des dvd sur des
images de 78 ans pendant les répétitions
tout ça pendant le concert mais c'est
vrai qu'il y est c'est la rive patron
aurait l'air réalisé
ça me ferait peut-être bizarre mais pour
un grand fan s'était mis
il est ici en pèlerinage
pendant deux semaines il va mettre ses
pas dans ceux de son idole et réalisé
son rêve d'adolescent avec sa femme son
plaisir aussi qui me fait plaisir d'être
là moi je profite du beau temps tout ça
mais c'est que je suis novice mme koné
[Musique]
une lune de miel sur un air de reggae
ces français ne sont pas les seuls à
trouver la jamaïque romantique dans un
hôtel à 200km de kingston nous avons un
rendez vous
c'est le grand jour pour au lit elle est
américaine elle a 27 ans à john et au
lit en espérant que ce jour soit parfait
pour vous
comme des centaines de compatriotes
chaque année elle se marie en jamaïque
après las vegas et hawaii l'île est une
des destinations phares du tourisme
nuptial
c'est ma robe de mariée et ma jolie
ceinture
toutes les filles aiment briller un peu
comment vous sentez vous je suis si
excitée nous sommes venus en jamaïque il
ya deux ans en vacances et mon fiancé ne
m'avait jamais vu aussi des temps dior
c'est donc l'endroit idéal pour se
marier c'est tellement simple d'être
détendu ici sa mère est au comble de
l'émotion
je suis impatiente fier je suis vraiment
très heureuse elle va être superbe
c'est une vraie organisatrice tout a été
prévu dans les moindres détails
maintenant je vais m'habiller à l'étagé
du dessus je sens super stressé vous
n'êtes pas prêt non il faut que je saute
dans ma douche costumes le bien connu
chez john le futur marié
question organisation c'est un peu moins
bien rodé
arch ans c'est son témoin eric qui se
chargera des détails essentiels
ce sera la bague de holly et celle de
john doit être dans l'autre boîte
la voici joli hein ma mission apporter
les anneaux et m'assurer que john ce
point je pense pour deux rendez vous
dans deux heures pour la cérémonie
john éoliens ont choisi le plus grand
hôtel de la jamaïque
alou 6e au nord-ouest de l'île il est
tellement grand que pour en faire le
tour
il vaut mieux emprunter une voiturette
de golf 1056 chambre
dix restaurants 12 bars cinq piscines
dont une géante
avec des semaines en formule all
inclusive tout inclus un concept
développé en jamaïque dans les années 80
on y croise aussi des rastas
c'est un chapeau qui recouvre les
cheveux gris
le all inclusive comprend aussi la
boisson à volonté au bar de la piscine
cocktail pour tout le monde dès potron
minet on se repose on passe du bon temps
c'est la fête ici ça a été comme ça
picole et bikini j'aime 17 picole et
bikini est ici y'a plein de cultures
différents tu rencontre plein de gens
on reste dans l'hôtel mais quelquefois
on sort on va faire un tour en
dirigeable dimanche admirer le paysage
passer un bon moment
la plupart de ses clients viennent
d'amérique du nord
pendant leur séjour ils quittent
rarement l'hôtel moment
oui sauf que à la une chose que je vais
faire une différence c'est ce que j'ai
été l'année dernière
dominique et républicaine et puis le
personnel sont pas aussi du plaisir ils
peuvent pas prendre des vols alors que
nous prend des boissons avec nous ils
peuvent pas jouer des jeux avec nous au
pire ici c'est frais c'est très facile
c'est vrai c'est beaucoup plus souple
aux hérésies cocktail soleil baignade un
tourisme xxl
ces vacances les français qui visitent
la jamaïque n'en veulent pas sur la côte
est
la région de port antonio
ces routes de campagne ces forêts
tropicales ici le tourisme est encore en
devenir
exactement ce que recherchait pauline et
isabelle elles viennent de la région
parisienne malgré leur petit budget
elles se sont offerts une semaine dans
cet hôtel tenu par des français
une piscine six bungalows au milieu d'un
jardin luxuriant 60 euros la nuit vous
prenez les bombes à moustiques
chaussures pour les dans l'eau si vous
en avez ce matin elles partent en
excursion avec romain le fils des
propriétaires précédents le problème
hier il est responsable de la partie
aventure des vacances cela vous chasser
du combien
[Musique]
pour ces jeunes femmes avoir un guide
qui parlent français c'est appréciable
[Musique]
sur la droite vous avez le terrain de
cricket au rang d'oignons c'est
en national ici c'est le sport le plus
regardé le plus aimé ensuite vient le
football et les dominos
ils considèrent les dominos comme un
sport en quelques stars soir
pour romain pas de problème avec la
conduite à gauche il vit ici depuis
qu'il a 15 ans il a passé son permis en
jamaïque
[Musique]
on va rester posés ici des arrêts
je sais comme ça à chaque endroit
une autre surprise les attend les
cascades de reach falls un des sites
naturels les plus réputés de la région
ce sur magnific confortable ça vaut les
tongs largement elles seront bien utiles
pour gravir les rochers et là vous allez
leclerc jamaïcain des richpoi
chevry
la baignade est autorisée et surveillée
mais rocher peuvent s'avérer dangereux
pour respirer ce parfum d'aventuré
pauline et isabelle ont payé 7 euros
chacune
en jamaïque l'entrée des plus beaux
sites naturels est toujours payante
pour le déjeuner ce sera sur le pouce au
bord de la route
elles vont goûter la spécialité
culinaire jamaïcaine le jerk en fait la
passagère
c'est le petit piment oiseau des
caraïbes qui sont broyés et mélangés
dans une sauce qui créent eux mêmes
qui rend gérant nourriture très très
épicé est-il aussi du bois de piment
reposer la viande dessus vous avez
remarqué
y a pas de grille en fait ici c'est le
bois déjà qui donne un à rome à la vie
en plus mais si vous voulez écouter et
puis c'est un tout petit peu c'est très
très difficile
de ce côté-là rend hélas aussi sauter
cette élection fait passionnant
comme l'andouillette pour les français
la jamaïque se mérite
il n'y a pas de vols directs depuis
paris et seuls deux tour opérateurs
proposent cette destination
il n'existe pas de formule clé en main
bon marché les deux amis ont dû
organiser leur voyage
elle-même faut vraiment réservé le vol
et un l'hôtel où enfin tout est à part
mais on s'en est sorti pour donner le
prix peut-être
ils doivent par personne sans compter
les dépenses personnelles on va dire sur
place avec les repas les visites en tout
chacune a en fait dépenser 1500 euros
pour deux semaines sur une plage de
l'autre côté de l'île
le mariage de john et holly sera bientôt
célébrer pendant leur séjour
eux n'ont pas prévu de quitter l'hôtel
ils sont venus avec leurs soixante
invités et leurs propres pasteur la
cérémonie proprement dite leur coûte
5000 euros elle a lieu à quelques mètres
des autres vacanciers
john est fin prêt
les pétales de roses peuvent tomber en
pluie sur le sable tous les pétales
viennent des bouquets que john lui a
offert ces cinq dernières années
elle les a tous gardé au lit fait son
entrée vêtue prendre au lit pour femmes
meilleur ami et partenaire dans l'amour
et le respect oui je le veux
elle est venue prendre donne pour marie
meilleur ami et partenaire au lit s'il
te plaît
[Rires]
[Musique]
loin bien loin de ce mariage de carte
postale
il y à une ville que le tourisme de
masse ignore totalement la capitale
kingston le taux de criminalité est l'un
des plus élevés au monde surtout dans
les quartiers du centre ce que les
américains appellent les ghettos gens le
fan de reggae a quand même décidé d'en
faire une étape de son pèlerinage rien
ne pourrait l'empêcher de visiter le
studio d'enregistrement de bob marley
tuff gong dans le ghetto de trenchtown
mais sans sa femme oriane qu'avez-vous
fait sa femme elle a trouvé un petit ami
la jeune épouse a déclaré forfait et se
repose à l'hôtel pour découvrir le
temple du reggae visites guidées
obligatoires ces trois caisses étaient
utilisés par bob marley bob marley a
fondé le studio en 1970 et depuis cette
époque c'est comme si rien n'avait
changé
m
mais devront mener pas un musée lusine
de disques de vinyle est toujours en
activité
car les artistes de reggae continuent
d'utiliser ce support
ça c'est un master vous voyez les
sillons sur lesquels sont enregistrés
les morceaux ensuite on met du vinyle à
l'intérieur et on chauffe
et sa faune sur le masters le clou de la
visite reste le studio tuff gong
appartient toujours à rita marley la
veuve du chanteur bernard lavilliers
serge gainsbourg ont enregistré des
albums ici bébé d'un mois un rythme pour
l'introduction
ce jour là les musiciens jamaïcains joue
pour un jeune groupe français
soul syndicate hands up trompeur
[Musique]
c'est quand même neuf donc c'est pour
nous à sa mythique chaque studio où
chaque endroit dans le monde n'a pas
forcément la même couleur donc venir ici
c'est avoir l'assurance d'avoir un bon
album reggae jean est aux anges
sur le tableau des visiteurs il écrit un
voeu beaucoup de choses ont eu lieu ici
il faut que ça continue
dans leurs programmes de visites jean et
oriane ne voulait pas se priver de cette
découverte de la capitale ni d'une
balade à pied à d'entendre le centre
ville un quartier où il est déconseillé
aux touristes de s'aventurer seul et
surtout de nuit
anthony leur chauffeur ne les lâchera
pas d'une semelle
elle est jeune comment ça va vous êtes
beau que dieu vous bénisse faut
peut-être pas non plus montré son côté
plus bling-bling tu vois faut pas aller
de balader avec des chaînes et des trucs
je pense mais après si tu te fond dans
le décor je parle pas mal aux gens je
les regarde pas dû
du dessus je vois pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils chercheraient des noises puisque
dans ces quartiers vie un tiers des
habitants de kingston pour certains dans
une très grande misère ici 60 % de la
population est au chômage
want you take j'utilise les petits pour
attraper les gros si j'attrape un
poisson j'aurai quelque chose à manger
aujourd'hui je vais lancer
écartez vous
non
c'est dimanche les jeunes du ghetto
profitent de leur pelage un moment
paisible
bien loin des clichés sur la violence de
kingston jean et oriane ne
s'éterniseront pas dans ce quartier un
territoire aux mains des trafiquants de
drogue ou les épisodes violents se
répète
comme il ya un peu plus d'un an
exactement au même endroit un
déploiement militaire impressionnant
l'armée et la police montent à l'assaut
du quartier de tivoli gardens pour
capturer le narcotrafiquant le plus
puissant de la jamaïque
des tirs et des bombardements après
quatre jours de scènes de guerre il y
aura 76 morts dont 73 civils
aujourd'hui le secteur portent encore
les stigmates de ces affrontements les
impacts de balles sur les immeubles des
habitations incendiées
pour visiter ce quartier où les
touristes ne vont pas nous aussi sommes
accompagnés
notre guide est une figure de tivoli
gardens razzle dazzle il a tout d'un
caïd son surnom on pourrait le traduire
par tape à l'oeil
peut-être à cause de ses bijoux et de
ses dents en or comme vous pouvez le
voir les gens m'appellent rasl je ne
sais pas pourquoi peut être est-ce ma
façon de m'habiller de me tenir
je me suis toujours occupé des jeunes et
de la communauté
à 55 ans c'est un proche du gang qui
règne sur le quartier mais il préfère se
présenter comme un bienfaiteur pour que
les jeunes évitent la rue et les armes
rasl leur a construit un studio
d'enregistrement comme il en existe
encore des dizaines à kingston lui ses
côtes icône c'est son nom d'artiste
c'est l'un de nos meilleurs artistes
dans le circuit
ce jour là la star est de corvée de
légumes rasl offre aussi le couvert une
journée ordinaire à tivoli gardens dans
les vapeurs de marijuana l'herbe est
officiellement illégal en jamaïque sa
consommation comme sa production dans le
studio cela ne semble dissuader
personnes
je fume pour mériter ça m'apprennent
j'aime la musique j'utilise la granja
pour l'inspiration
ouais mec c'est de la bonne méditation
de bonnes vibrations
vous n'avez pas de problèmes avec la
police si on peut avoir des problèmes
avec les flics dans la rue tu dois 10
créatures sur mme harel je dois payer
une amende résolve voit grand il veut
créer un lieu incontournable dans le
ghetto ils rêvent d'y voir un jour des
touristes sera-t-il entendu
c'est une scène et ici il y aura un bar
raid où trouvez-vous l'argent oh mon
dieu
parfois je pris officiellement
l'argent viendrait de petits commerces
et de dons divers rasl ne s'étendra pas
sur ce sujet
parmi ses protégés il y as garé vinh il
a 22 ans et comme tous les autres il est
au chômage
sa jambe il l'a perdue à cause d'une
fusillade
il avait 12 ans je quitte l école je
rentrais chez moi
si on m'a tiré dessus accidentellement
j'ai été blessé à la jambe il a fallu
l'amputer
cela arrive souvent ici d'une certaine
manière saine il faut faire attention
aux endroits vous allez il vit dans une
petite communauté typique des
bidonvilles de kingston avec une partie
de sa famille des voisins
une vingtaine de personnes qui se
partagent les commodités voici la salle
de bain
il est né au coeur du ghetto et il n'en
sortira probablement jamais une
frontière invisible
c'est par ces quartiers du reste du pays
[Musique]
en jamaïque jusqu'à présent l'ultra
violence des ghettos n'a jamais atteint
les complexes touristiques les deux
mondes s'ignorent
derrière les murs d'enceinte des hôtels
les voyageurs passent des jours
tranquilles au milieu de leur voyage
jean et oriane savourer un moment de
détente
aucune ombre ne vient assombrir ce
tableau idyllique
les gens sont très sympas
on m'a fait vraiment de belles balades
il
vous souvenez enfin lancée
il ne s'en doute pas encore mais le
moment le plus intense du séjour reste à
venir
une visite que j'en attends depuis ses
14 ans ils vont se recueillir sur la
tombe de bob marley à l'intérieur des
terres en pleine campagne
là où il repose depuis 30 ans les
français espère t-il trouvé une
atmosphère quasi religieuse mais depuis
la mort de l'idole
le lieu a bien changé il faut d'abord
payer l'entrée 15 euros par personne
puis traversez la boutique de souvenirs
à l'effigié de bob
non je pense que lui verrait ça il serai
pas content non ce ne serait pas content
je m'attendais pas du tout à ça ils
n'achèteront pas de souvenirs mais
n'éviteront pas les petits suppléments
brûler un cierge en hommage à la légende
c'est un dollar la bougie merci bonne
visite
monter à l'étagé attendez votre livre
[Musique]
rien que pour le guide la visite vaut le
détour
bienvenue bienvenue ah non désolé mais
petit coeur j'aurais dû saluer les
femmes avant les hommes c'est une
célébrité
thank you and i auto mon enseigne aux
tonneaux au limon
enfin non seulement ma mère m'appelle
comme ça le captaine crazy
grâce aux vidéos des touristes sur
internet
le rire de captain crazy a fait le tour
du monde c'est leïla ian ainslie
aïe aïe aïe mais c'est aussi un
excellent chanteur au delà de ce portail
seules les photos sont autorisés jean et
oriane nous ont ouvert leur album
souvenir la petite maison où le chanteur
est née la chapelle dans laquelle son
corps repose genci recueillera seul
[Musique]
l'émotion a failli lui faire oublier un
détail wal à anoeta mieux vaut
d'ailleurs il vient d'un gars je t'aime
mec respect éclatez vous en jamaïque
comme souvent en jamaïque l'histoire va
se terminer en musique
[Musique]